you're suffering
i'm counting on there
Welcome back everyone this will be my full thor
love and thunder deleted scenes alternate ending
video there's a bunch of stuff that got cut
from the movie it was supposed to be like four
hours long when taika watiti started cutting it
down so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're doing a giveaway for imax
tickets for the movie all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just leave your favorite
easter egg from the movie on the video careful
for spoilers for the movie if you haven't seen
it yet because we'll be talking about everything
but one of the first deleted scenes is the opening
scene with gorr's character when he kills the
gods of his people after getting the necro sword
gorr's daughter winds up dying and there was the
scene of him crying this blood curling scream
that marvel just deemed too horrific for the movie
but then right after gorr kills his gods with the
necro sword that was meant to be a scene of him
mutilating himself to remove all of his religious
tattoos which is why he has so many tattoos at
the beginning of the film but he has all the
scars all over his face in his body at the end
of the film natalie portman revealed that there
were whole worlds whole sequences of the movie
that got deleted early in the movie christian
bale also revealed that there was a scene of
gorr visiting the grand master on sakhar there
was also some other deleted scenes connected
to that too that i'll mention in a second
there was also a deleted scene of gorr visiting e
tree the dwarf on the dwarven home world it sounds
like he was trying to kill him to prevent him from
creating more weapons powerful enough to face the
necrosword he would have basically tried to kill
e3 to prevent him from creating more weapons like
the infinity gauntlet because thanos forced him
to create the gauntlet itself and if he hadn't
had done that it would have been way harder
for thanos to actually snap half the universe
some of the larger deleted scenes the portions of
the movie that natalie portman was talking about
also took place during the guardians of the galaxy
scenes early in the film like there's a scene of
thor walking away from one of their battles in the
trailers like he's given up on war there's also a
deleted scene of him doing voice over talking
about how he's chosen this path of peace and
he tries to get all zen with him sitting under
the tree there was a lot of his speech early on
with the guardians that they got rid of where
he's joking to them about his crappy idea of a
holiday and a relaxing vacation then connected
to these early scenes where he's going around
learning about the path of gorr it seems like
there's a scene of valkyrie on a planet with thor
that looks like sakar because there's all these
trash piles behind them and that might have been
connected to the scenes of him learning about
what happened to sakhara the grandmaster and gorr
tessa thompson also revealed that there
was a longer scene of her just literally
talking straight to the goats like she was really
enamored with the goats themselves when thor and
the guardians of the galaxy are looking at all
the different distress calls coming in from all
over the universe deciding who to help next and
why they have to split up because there's so many
most of the scenes are meant to be comic book
references like directly comic book panels taken
out of the gorr storyline meant to show all the
brutal takedowns the gorr has killing all these
different gods before he fights thor for the first
time one of these scenes originally was also meant
to address him going after the gods from moon
knight that you saw conscious pantheon of gods
originally the moon knight people revealed they
were going to have a crossover between thor love
and thunder and moon knight with the gorr of the
god butcher character because early on in moon
knight i think it was around moon knight episode
3 they come in talking about how they're missing
two of the members of their pantheon their ruling
council the idiot what was going to happen is that
they were going to enter the finale walking
in getting ready to fight arthur harrow and
ahmed who was coming back while also complaining
about gorr of the god butcher by that time having
learned that it was gorr the god butcher that
had killed two of the members of their pantheon
but just for reference khonsuh's pantheon the
ennead are featured during the godhead scene
if you look at some of the other time material you
can see khonshu's pantheon the egyptian gods of
what would have been happening in the background
of this larger godhead scene they're meant to
be hundreds of gods like every god that you
could possibly imagine from marvel comics every
reference is meant to be included in this scene
during the godhead scene originally one of the
biggest changes they made was going to be with
russell crowe zeus himself and his cameo scene
originally they revealed that he was going to
be playing a version of satan that's right satan
his appearance was going to be closer to the
traditional appearance of the satan character
in the comics there's this group of what they call
class 2 demons that comprise what's known as the
marvel hell lords they're like the greater god
level beings that rule over dimensions that are
similar to the concept of hell with each of them
ruling over a different dimension being equally
powerful class 1 demons are meant to be like
the highest level of demons in the mcu those
are basically meant to be like the elder gods
like cathode the god of chaos they referenced
him briefly during doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness he's the person who created the temple
on mount wondagor and he's the person who gave
chaos magic to scarlet witch when she was born
he's the reason why she became the scarlet witch
those elder gods the older gods in the mc are the
ones that built actual omnipotent city all the
hell lords like mephisto satan came after them
like zeus for instance came after the elder gods
they're less powerful but still super powerful
but that's why in the movie they gave zeus the
backstory that within the mcu he's supposed to
be the oldest living god and one of the most
powerful currently at least according to thor
which is why he's supposed to be the leader
of this verse of the godhead and all the other
gods defer to him the whole concept with him being
satan in the movie i think was more about all the
gods being so terrible that you'd root for gorr
more to actually kill them like gorr was right
the reason they changed him to zeus instead of
satan is mostly just to service the plot and
move things along even quicker and explain where
they get his thunderbolt from otherwise they would
have had to steal satan's trident or something
like that also during these scenes they revealed
there was going to be a longer deleted scene with
lena heady playing a version of hera zeus's wife
and obviously they had all these jokes where zeus
is super promiscuous like the joke that their most
important matter was trying to pick where their
next party was going to be even though gorr was
going around killing all these gods you have to
picture their relationship as being like cersei
and robert baratheon like she couldn't stand him
the same way that they depict hera and zeus in
the comics as well as in pop culture like hera
typically really upset with how promiscuous zeus
gets there's also a really big x-men connection
here in the godhead scene too when they feature
the god of magic and the god of dreams this giant
floating eyeball is actually meant to be aura
sarada the god of aracho in the new x-men comics
that's like the sister island of krakowa the
hidden mutant island that all the x-men hide out
on the islands themselves are like living entities
it's meant to be this whole arc that completely
re-envisions what's happening with the x-men
inside the mcu very much one of those situations
where x-men have been inside this universe the
whole time but hiding out in the mcu right now
the closest thing we have to that right now like
a secret island that nobody's been talking about
is timoth's body the body that dead celestial the
early theory right now is that the avengers will
eventually make their next base inside the body
of this dead celestial because it's so powerful
and so advanced which is something that they did
in the comics but that was completely separate
from the x-men krakowa plot one of the other
bigger x-men fantastic four connections too
is through the galactus plot because galactus
is featured in the epilogue for the gorr of the
god butcher storyline in the comics during that
storyline they also have multiple versions of
thor but it's more of like a loki kang kind of
thing with different versions of thor from across
his timeline all fighting together like young thor
current virgin thor and then old man future thor
originally there was this epilogue where you have
this alternate future timeline where the earth
has died off loki has done something to basically
bork the entire planet and humanity has died off
thousands of years in the future you have old man
thor fighting a version of galactus who's come
to earth this dying and is going to feed on it
because it's meant to be one of the last places
where he can find a meal and galactus himself is
running out of planets that he can consume for
energy an old man thor uses the necro sword to
stop galactus but then galactus winds up absorbing
the necro sword and becoming the butcher of worlds
like the reference is that gorr is the god butcher
galactus is the hunker of worlds but when he gets
the necro sword he becomes galactus butcher of
worlds the only bad part about that story is that
because secret warts happened right after that
it rebooted the whole timeline and marvel never
really did anything with galactus with a version
of the necro sword would have been really cool
during the earlier part of the film before they go
to omnipotent city there were a bunch of deleted
scenes with jane foster's version of thor so there
was a deleted scene of her getting the power of
the hammer with it reforming and her gaining all
this cosmic power because there was also a series
of deleted scenes that happened where valkyrie and
jane foster as thor spend a lot of time together
before thor comes back to new asgard there are
meant to be a lot more scenes of them together
when she gets the power of thor bonding and then
being kind of like sisters during the film like
valkyrie really wanted to bring the valkyrie core
back and she finds jane foster's store and they
kind of act like sisters again there was also a
deleted subplot about valkyrie selecting who the
next queen of asgard was going to be like she's
supposed to be king of asgard originally there
was a storyline where she finds someone to marry
and become her queen there was also meant to be
a full-on crazy thor dance sequence like in the
vein of star lords dance off to save the universe
set to abba's waterloo where thor shoots lightning
out of his hands i think it was meant to be in
the same energy as star-lord's dance-off sequence
because so much of thor is loving the guardians of
the galaxy and just being inspired by a lot of the
things that they do christian bale also revealed
that gorr had his own dance sequence was meant
to riff on thor's earlier dance sequence but it
was meant to be a kate bush kind of thing and the
reason they didn't do in the movie as you guessed
it is because stranger things used the kate bush
running up that hill song and it turned into this
big thing so they just had to cut it out of the
movie some of the other deleted scenes that you
spot in the trailers too are meek's whiteboard
so in the trailers the whiteboard just tells you
everything that's happened in the movie so far but
in the final version of the movie they completely
change what's on this whiteboard and it basically
reveals the entire rest of the plot of the film
because you basically see like everything
that happens with the guardians of the galaxy
everything that happens in omnipotent city with
them fighting zeus and then everything later in
the movie with eternity before they've learned
what happens with eternity like at this point
in the film with this is on the whiteboard they
don't know anything about eternity yet during
the trailers there are also much longer versions
of the scenes in omnipotent city where they're
fighting zeus's men just embellishing more kills
like the scene of valkyrie licking your sword
wasn't in the final version of the movie they also
changed some of the other scenes of valkyrie when
they first go back to asgard and play the guns and
roses paradise city song where you see her being
really bored in the trailers you just see her
rolling her eyes having to do all this day-to-day
stuff in the final version of the movie you see
her playing with her little knife so like i said
taco batiti explained there's like four hours
of deleted scenes of this movie but a lot of it
is just a lot of jokes that he felt like after
the fact didn't work like the dance sequences
we probably could have done without all the thor
dance sequences but it would be fun if some of
those are included on the blu-ray if you spotted
any other deleted scenes in the trailers or
learned about any other alternate endings that i
didn't talk about during the video just write them
below in the comments i've got a bunch of bonus
videos planned we have marvel comic-con trailers
coming in a couple weeks too there's a bunch of
big stuff including the black panther 2 trailer
that they're supposed to be bringing to comic-con
this year of course i'll do videos for everything
so make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here for my thor love and thunder full breakdown
for the entire movie easter eggs for everything
and click here for my loki season 2 first look
video to find out what's happening during that
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!